[Music]
thank you all very much I'm going to
talk about the ethics of the Internet of
Things and I promise that I'm not going
to lecture you too much I'm Emily Gorski
I'm on Twitter I say things there
sometimes but I'm really interested in
in the Internet of Things and the
landscape that is creating so why am I
talking about
the Internet of Things at a JavaScript
conference why am i talking about ethics
at a JavaScript conference and it's
because I've given this talk a few times
and I joke that some that every time I
give it I can give a brand new talk
because there are so many issues there
are so many failures and bugs and
security issues that come up so
frequently that if I just focus on case
studies it'll be a brand new talk every
time and this time I've decided that I
don't want to give this talk anymore I
want you all to be able to give this
talk so I want to talk a little bit more
generally about why ethics matters light
should matter to you as a JavaScript
developer and what we can do as we go
through the future of putting javascript
putting technology into all sorts of
devices and services where it doesn't
normally belong it's almost impossible
to do an ethics talk without getting
into some really heavy stuff so there
are some content warnings for this talk
we can talk frankly about some incidents
that resulted in injury and depth of
people there's going to be a discussion
of a specific incident of sexual assault
and I'm going to have an image of Rami
so that kind of spits you out like it
does me that'll be about maybe ten
minutes into the talk so Who am I I have
a little bit of a confession I'm kind of
an impostor here because I'm not a
JavaScript developer the last time I
wrote JavaScript seriously ojos talk was
still the future I'm a data scientist
and I'm trained as a mathematician but
also as an engineer I went to school for
aeronautical engineering mechanical
engineering and I've worked in my career
in the aerospace biotech and now I work
in the finance industries and what these
industries have in common is that
they're all heavily regulated and most
of the people working in them subscribe
to a professional code of ethics through
either an independent Society or some
other organization that helped that
guides what ethical conduct means so you
know here I am I work in defense I
worked in health care and now I'm
working in banking and I'm going to talk
to you about ethics so buckle in when I
talk about the Internet of Things what
is it that I mean like there's it's kind
of a wishy-washy definition we might
think about like smart fridges or smart
cars that sort of thing
I like to think of it as putting the
Internet where it doesn't normally
belong so it could be smart appliances
but I also think of things like uber as
an IOT taxi so when we when we look at
the ethics of that we have to look at
the entire scope of what are we doing
with our technology what are we
connecting and the difference is that
it's not that where these devices or
these products and services haven't been
computerized it's that we're letting the
consumer have connectivity to what's
going on so if your JavaScript developer
maybe you want an IOT bread machine so
that you can keep hacking on your code
well your bread bakes and this is this
is important because IOT products are
the next level of convenience
optimization we've spent the last 30
years optimizing products for
convenience and there's not much more
competitive advantage that you can get
in a refrigerator nowadays so if you
don't have a competitive advantage with
a non connected device you have to go
connected this is also important for
people whose livelihoods are affected by
disability you might be interested you
might be concerned about like the
surveillance capabilities of IOT devices
or you know the horrible things that
uber has been accused of doing but if
you're not able to get around or if
you're not able to if you don't live in
a place where there's easy taxi service
and you have other needs something like
uber is is a lifesaver and it really
changes your life so we can't just write
it off as an absurdity we can't just say
that IOT is something that is frivolous
or like a toy that's you know we have
the Internet of [ __ ] Twitter account
it's hilarious and there's a lot of
misses in there but there's a lot of
good things that comes out of IOT as
well and when I talk about ethics what
is it that I mean when I when I say that
word
you know the trolley problem is really
popular right now because of
self-driving cars and you've probably
seen this diagram and the framing goes
you know there's one Nobel laureate tied
to one set of tracks and there's five
normal people tied to another and
somehow you have been put in the
position of pulling the lever and this
is a really popular problem on the
internet right now because one it feels
like something that we can solve with
category theory if we just abstract it
enough and two it makes your some really
dank memes the thing about the trolley
problem is the trolley problem wasn't
even a problem for trolleys so why do we
think it's going to be a problem for
self-driving cars we love to try to
frame things as ethical dilemmas that
are puzzles to solve that's our nature
as developers and engineers
the thing is in tech we don't actually
face ethical dilemmas that often ethical
dilemmas happen when there are two
competing ethical frameworks and an
action that you take cannot not be in
violation of at least one of them and
what I think is fascinating about
JavaScript is that the JavaScript
community is responsible for what I
consider to be the most fascinating
that's a true ethical dilemma
in a decade of technology I'll get to
that a little bit later some of you
probably know exactly what I'm talking
about already the issue with technology
is that we just often don't act with
ethics and I don't mean this as an
indictment I don't mean to say like
you're bad in ethical immoral human
beings there are some companies out
there that are going to get a side-eye
right now but what I mean by this is
that our industry we don't have a
professional code there are some
societies that you can join but raise
your hand if you're so that if you're a
member of like ACM or I Triple E
I mean there's a few of you out there
but it's not the majority in practice
ethics are about two things they're
about the analysis of harm and the
mitigation of risk so when we talk about
acting ethically especially in something
like research ethics what we're doing is
we're not trying to eliminate the
possibility of somebody getting hurt but
we're trying to understand all of the
ways that somebody might be hurt by our
technology and we're looking for how
what actions we can take to mitigate the
chance of that happening to mitigate the
severity of it when it happens and to
provide remediation when it inevitably
does so this is what we need to build up
as our ethical framework when we're
developing technology particularly for
IOT so harm can happen in three ways the
first is through malfeasance this is the
most common top topic in IOT this is
security this is people talking about
hacking when the mayor I bought net had
a do s attack last fall that was a huge
issue there was it was the biggest VOS
attack ever witnessed and it was be
happened through IOT devices that were
unsecured and you probably know that I
wrote e security is in a pretty abysmal
state right now and when this happened
the timing of it and the way that it was
structured gave a lot of people a lot of
concerns that it was a precursor to an
attack on the u.s. presidential election
and that this would be an attempt to
influence the outcome of that election
as it turns out those fears are
unfounded we managed to screw that one
up all by ourselves but I don't want to
talk about security in this talk because
first I can't cover everything second
the other two ways that harm can happen
through failures and edge cases if we
address those we also address many of
the security issues so failures are
things like bugs and software and then
edge cases happen when a device is
acting under normal nominal operating
circumstances but it gets put into a
condition that we did not predict as
developers and it's also worth
mentioning that sometimes we like to
treat bugs as edge cases and edge cases
as bugs so there's not really a lot of
difference
there except for semantics it's a great
example of this this was on Twitter this
poor gentleman Andrew had an IOT
water-cooler and his TLS certificate
expired which led to some blocking code
which meant that a hardware interlocks
failed and he has water all over his
house and this is a real issue right
like this is this is a problem if a TLS
certificate expires in a web service
there like a forum in the web space and
we forget a TLS certificate and we have
blocking code that's like ops problem we
have ops people to deal with that but we
can't treat IOT devices like cattle
anymore we have to treat them like pets
we have to treat IOT devices like pets
that live in people's homes and get very
very angry when they don't get fed one
day if we're not careful we're going to
put JavaScript into I don't know an IOT
tea kettle and then it's going to light
somebody's house on fire because
undefined is not a function I stole that
joke from Laurie Vasa by the way which
is total payback because he didn't save
me NPM socks this is this is something
that I did that I'm very proud of this I
did this a couple years ago so we'll go
fullscreen on this if I can if I can
figure out where my mouse is there we go
so this is a Microsoft band and I'm not
picking on Microsoft's at all here and
this is a piece of raw chicken and what
you'll see is I didn't do anything
horrible to a chicken like have a zombie
chicken out there this is just a piece
of meat that I bought from the from the
grocery store and as you can see there's
it's reading a heart rate of about 120
beats per minute in the real world
censors are messy they're noisy they're
imperfect and so when we're designing
for IOT we have to take this into
consideration this is absurd that you
can read a heart rate off of a piece of
chicken breast but this actually has
deep deep ramifications for a lot of
things for one there are colleges out
there that are mandating students wear
fitbit's there are employers out there
that
have incentive health insurance and
scented programs for doing this and if
you're following what's happening with
American health care now we have this
issue where we have surveillance devices
that are monitoring our health and can
report on pre-existing conditions but
this is actually not just hypothetical
this is something that's really happened
let me get out of full-screen mode as I
can
2015 a woman was visiting a co-worker in
Lancaster Pennsylvania she called police
to report a sexual assault
when police investigated they found her
Fitbit and with her permission they
analyzed the data and when they analyzed
the data not only did they drop the
investigation into her claims but they
turned around and they charged her with
making false statements to the police
and last year she pled guilty to those
charges and was convicted and put on
probation the prosecuting attorney said
that the Fitbit data sealed the deal I
can pull 120 beats per minute off of a
piece of raw chicken and a woman's life
is ruined because nobody has Fitbit
stood up and said no our devices are not
the FAQ Yura you can't do that our
devices bear false witness against us or
they can and the problem is that there's
no regulation there's no Quality
Assurance there's no standards for how
we build them we just ship code we just
ship hardware we make the next thing we
innovate fast fast fast and we don't ask
ourselves what can what kinds of harm
can happen when this goes wrong and this
is happening increasingly often these
devices are being used in criminal and
civil investigations just last week on
CNN reported that a man is being charged
with murder of his wife
based on the Fitbit data that she had
that said that she travelled a certain
distance and that distance did not
correlate with his story but anybody
that's knitted for example while wearing
one will know that it will record steps
while you're sitting on your couch how
can we do this what how can we let this
happen how can we let this information
affect people's lives another incident
I saw a smart water meter was used in a
murder investigation last year in that
same investigation they also filed a
warrant for Amazon echo data the
question is who's going to go to jail
who's going to get put on probation when
it
vice makes false statements to the
police moreover say something happens
say something breaks and somebody gets
hurt or somebody gets killed who's going
to be liable if that device causes an
accident is it the owner is it the
developer the company that made it and
it seems like it should be a settled
question but it's actually not and this
has already happened in this frame
you'll see the vehicle the white vehicle
on the right is a Google self-driving
car and this image is a still image or
this is a screen capture from a video
taken from the dashcam of a municipal
bus in Mountain View California this is
right before a historical moment that
Google SUV is about to pull out in front
of the bus and get in an accident
thankfully nobody was hurt in this note
there were no injuries it was just a
fender bender but this is the first time
that a self-driving car has ever been
found responsible for causing an
accident
Google fest up to this they said you
know what our bad you know we'll take
care of the damages and they
investigated what happened and they
concluded that the car predicted that
the bus would yield to us because we
were ahead of it okay now Google is in a
position right now where they want to
ship self-driving cars so of course
they're going to assume liability for
this because they don't want to test it
in court but we can't rely on that as we
go into the IOT feature we cannot rely
on benevolent corporations to assume
liability once this goes out at scale by
the way even if Google was right this
was still going to be a historical
moment because if that bus had yielded
to that vehicle it would be the first
time in history that a municipal bus has
ever yielded
a few years ago there's a judge in San
Francisco and this is part of a research
project this is not part of a case he
looked into the question of whether
autonomous systems fall under existing
theories of liability and in looking
into it he found that vehicles that make
their own decisions that use things like
neural nets that use adaptive self
adjusting control systems smart smart
systems if you will devising their own
means suzana tasks may not be subject to
liability under any existing theories of
tort and this has huge implications
because if you buy a normal refrigerator
and it breaks you can say hey
manufacturer you're responsible for that
break or if you you know buy a
coffeemaker and it burns down your house
because of a defective unit you can go
and you know you get out safely and then
you recover damages from the company and
your insurance company takes care of it
and there's a whole ethical framework
that's built up around this and there's
a legal structure that's there as well
obviously self-driving cars are going to
be safer they're going to save lives
that's a very important thing we want to
save lives we want the roads to be
better but the number of lives save is
not the only term in our ethical
calculus we also have to look at what
happens when people get injured how are
they taken care of how are they able to
pay their medical bills or get back to
work or miss work while they're
recovering but still be able to pay rent
and afford food so the question about
this is what does this mean for us as
developers like does this give us a free
pass we're not liable for IOT devices
that means we can ship right we can do
whatever we can innovate and let's just
innovate the hell out of everything
until something breaks and and there's a
precedent right is that really the
legacy that we want to leave behind do
we want to leave the legacy behind us we
did it because we could and we didn't
give a damn about who we tart
some companies are doing this some
companies are actually still working in
a space where they just want to innovate
and they just want to build things and
shiftings
and they'll deal with the consequences
later but you have to ask yourself do I
want to be responsible for that
and that's what ethics is all about now
I said that javascript the JavaScript
community had one of the most
fascinating ethical incidents and
technology in a while and that's the
left pad incident and I don't know why
it's pink but whatever when Ashley
talked about left pad last night it was
really fascinating because she focused
on a lot of the backlash like she said
the internet blew up when left had
happened and people were angry about a
lot of things people were angry about
the way that javascript community has
developed small module system and maybe
it's wrong or maybe it's right and there
was a lot of argument back and forth and
friendships were lost or damaged in this
incident and what people didn't realize
was that the reason for all of this
anger and acrimony was because the Left
pad incident actually exposed what is a
true ethical dilemma and we just didn't
see the forest for the trees at the
moment because left pad had two
competing ethical decisions the first is
the hacker culture ethic that openness
is the most important thing that
openness of virtue and that the ability
to control your code is tantamount to
being a hacker to being an open source
developer sure other people can fork it
but you can choose where you're going to
put it and so in the left eye developer
pulled all of his modules and broke a
bunch of stuff on the internet
NPM also had a competing ethical
framework which is that they have a
responsibility to the people that use
their product they have a responsibility
as engineers they also value openness
they're an open source community so this
was a very hard decision then that's why
there were so many you know so many
heads being but over
over the decision that was made but
could you imagine what would have
happened if this didn't happen in 2016
when it mostly affected the web but
rather in I don't know 2018 2020 when
NPM is running on people's cars people's
refrigerators somebody pulls down a
module and now of a sudden you're
driving down the highway at 70 miles an
hour and your car shuts off or something
goes wrong and you think oh well that
couldn't ever happen nobody would
actually you know do live deployments on
a car and running or an IOT device
that's running in the field please like
we're doing it in production systems
right now IOT security is a mess we're
doing this rapid innovation pace of
course there's going to be issues and
you don't want to be the person that's
responsible for somebody's refrigerator
going out they lose all their food or
maybe they lose their important medicine
that needs refrigeration you don't be
responsible for that or maybe you do
maybe you think that the virtue of
openness is the moat is the more
important ethic and that is a true
ethical dilemma so what do we do as
engineers what are the takeaways that we
can have when we talk about ethics and
this is kind of why one is why I said I
wanted to you know not give this talk
and rather empower you to be able to
give this talk because there are
actionable things that we can do as
engineers as developers to make our
workspaces better to act with more
ethics the first one would be set
expectations with your boss if you know
what your what pressures your boss has
if they ask you to do something that you
don't feel comfortable with you need to
know like hey can I go to my boss and
say I don't I don't feel comfortable
with this can you go to your to your
manager and say I have concerns over
this and you know what process will
happen if you do that that's an
important thing you also have to be
prepared to say no if somebody comes to
you and says hey I need you to build in
this method that sends tracking data
somebody's heart rate back to our server
in real-time are you comfortable doing
that maybe you're not but do you know
how to do do you know how to refuse an
order are you willing to refuse an order
to put your career in jeopardy for doing
so if it goes against something that you
believe in you need to also be able to
hold frank discussions with your
co-workers about what this means I work
in finance and I'm a data scientist so
we have a vast amount of data on people
and a vast amount of capability to do
things with that data and so we talked
often my team we talk often about the
implications of what we're doing when we
record customer data when we record
information about their finances we talk
all the time like what are you not
willing to do or you know what are we
legally obligated to do we because in
finance we have legal obligations in
terms of reporting fraud in terms of
looking for money laundering for example
so we have to talk about these things
with each other and as engineers you
should be able to talk about talk
frankly with your co-workers about I
don't like where this is going or I have
concerns how do we make sure that it
doesn't go there how do we make sure we
stay in the safe side and not the
dangerous side and the most important
thing is to know your limit its to know
when you're willing to walk away because
tech is really lucrative and we have a
lot of privilege we have a lot of
privilege in tech if even just look
around the space that we're in this is a
remarkable conference in a remarkable
space and there's amenities and all
sorts of decadence here and not every
industry is like this so what is your
limit that you would be willing to say I
can no longer in good conscience
continue to do this and go do something
different and if you don't know what
that limit is you're not going to
discover that you're over it until it's
too late
that's all I have thank you very much
[Applause]
you